what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so picking up with the conclusion
of blackest night we're finally here
we're finally done something like ten
videos later we're finally finished with
blackest night God this story's lengthy
brightest day is even longer but the
cool thing is that brightest day does
not have nearly as many interesting
tie-ins so that'll actually be done and
probably around like anywhere between
four to six videos and will take
anywhere near as long so uh when it
comes to blackest night again we're
basically dealing with the end of
everything we're dealing with the
conclusion of the event which is to say
this final battle between the Black
Lanterns as well as all the other
Lantern cores and the superheroes who
were trying to stop them now something I
want to point out here because over the
course of the blackest night series I've
been looking through the comments but
you guys have been leaving with like a
lot of questions and different things
like that and one of the most common
questions that I've seen is if Necron is
like the living embodiment of death in
the Green Lantern universe when it comes
to the emotional spectrum then how does
DC consolidate that and how do they make
that work with like death of the endless
and different things along those lines
and so here's the deal a little bit of a
little bit of explanation here and when
it comes to comic books you will
oftentimes have entities that will
represent the same thing multiple
entities will represent the same thing
sometimes coming book publishers make an
effort to consolidate that and make it
make sense and sometimes they don't when
it comes to the Green Lantern line of
stories and DC Comics
when it first launched it was very much
in line with a lot of the DC stuff but
the more popular it became the more DC
began to adopt the mindset if it works
don't fix it and so what they ended up
doing was basically telling Geoff Johns
do what you want to do as long as it
fits in with the continuity of stories
we don't really care what goes on and so
what ended up happening is who is
creating all these different entities
and things like that
nekron is the living embodiment of death
how that reconciles with like death of
the endless I don't know
now the the continuity sticklers this
will drive them nuts they will go crazy
over this but you just kind of have to
roll with it you have to go with it it's
the nature of comics it does make things
a little bit confusing and it does make
things a little strange but continuing
on with this whole scenario because of
the fact that all the roads of these
different characters are leading to
earth which is to say Guy Gardner and
Kyle Rayner and the Green Lantern Corps
you know basically traveling to earth
because that's where the brunt of the
conflict of blackest night is taking
place with Jon Stewart of the Green
Lantern's traveling to earth because
that's where a brunt of the conflict is
taking place all these stories begin to
consolidate into
one giant amalgamation of everything
going on in a singular location but keep
in mind when it comes to the the stories
that we've seen so far one of the things
that we found was that there was a black
lantern planet called zhanchi a planet
that have previously been destroyed by
the actions of Jon Stewart of the Green
Lantern's the result is that the planet
itself was made into a black lantern and
then housed all these people that had
died on it wood had exploded and they
became black lanterns as well and so
with Jon Stewart showing up basically
making amends with his past mistakes and
then leading zhanchi directly to earth
this meant that this whole planet and
all these black Lantern's on it come
flying back towards Earth now at the
same time keep in mind the idea of the
black Lantern's attacking members of the
different course is still there and they
all do it in their own individual way
but keep in mind but whenever we talked
about ideas were coming book publishers
were like Marvel or DC was testing the
waters and they were bringing characters
back and they were basically doing soft
reboots that's what this is you're
literally learning about this in real
time the whole event of blackest night
is just pick and choose what characters
get to come back and what characters
don't but it also hits at the very
nature of the characters themselves with
Kyle Rayner there was a woman in his
life by the name of Alex do it and Alex
DeWitt was really one of the huge really
one of the biggest controversial
characters out there because of the way
in which she died and when it comes to
DC there's a character called major
force and major force was a guy who was
created by Kerry Bates and Greg Weissman
I think it was and so the whole idea was
that major force was basically a guy who
was working for something called the
quorum organization I think and this
really coincided with the establishment
of Kyle Rayner being the Green Lantern
the idea of the quorum organization
which was just this really clandestine
corrupt aspect to the US government was
to basically get the power of the Green
Lantern but they could not directly
challenge Kyle Rayner because of how
powerful he was and so the idea was to
demoralize him and have one of two
things happen either he gives up or
they're able to basically just take him
out in a moment of weakness and so what
had happened is that under the direction
of the form organization major force
killed Alex do it the girlfriend of Kyle
Rayner basically broke every single bone
in her body and then crumpled her in a
refrigerator and it was a massive
controversy when that happened because
it created this archetype that like love
interests always just quote unquote end
up in refrigerators women in
refrigerators kind of a fun fact other
writer one of the writers at the time
Cale
Symone actually launched a website
called women in refrigerators dot-com I
think and that's what that phrase came
from but the whole idea was that it
established this precedent the cow Waner
can never find love every woman he falls
in love with will eventually die but the
idea is that with kyle rayner facing off
against the Black Lanterns
Alex duet comes back as one now remember
the Black Lanterns served the purpose of
basically manipulating people forcing
them to feel a wide array of different
emotions and then when their hearts are
completely charged you know consuming
that emotion basically killing them and
then turning him into Black Lanterns and
turned and so in this instance what Alex
do it does is actually taught kyle
rayner
over and over again by giving him a
description of everything that major
force had done when he killed her
because remember all Kyle Rayner knew is
he came home and he just found her
stuffed in a refrigerator and that was
it what this does is it goes through
line by line in his says major force
broke every single bone in her body
broke her spine broke her neck the whole
nine yards and then stuffed her in a
fridge but by forcing Kyle Rayner to
relive this massively traumatic moment
in his life the goal of the Black
Lanterns is to turn him is to basically
put him in a moment of weakness kill him
take his heart and then turn him into a
black lantern the funny thing about this
is remember he already experienced this
at the hands of Jade another love
interest who had basically died Kyle
Rayner had experienced this emotional
manipulation and so as one of those
things were it's like fool me once shame
on you fool me twice shame on me
and so he's not as easily manipulated
because he sees right through the guys
he's not emotionally taunted now this is
important because one of the things that
I hope you guys notice over the course
of the blackest night event and even
over the course of everything we've done
in Geoff Johns run is it's building up
the character of Kyle Rayner emotionally
psychologically it's building him up to
a guy where he can basically withstand
virtually anything and that will become
exceedingly important later on down the
line
but again because of the fact that this
is everybody you're really trying to
deal with the Black Lanterns and trying
to figure out a way to end the Black
Lanterns coming across their central
power battery the source of all their
energy what we discover is the fate of
the anti-monitor now remember during the
end of Sinestro Corps war when the
anti-monitor was basically revealed to
have been resurrected when the
multiverse came back after Infinite
Crisis when we ended up having this
whole idea that the anti-monitor joined
Sinestro he was more or less kind of the
the harbinger of the core and then
ultimately was defeated by the guardians
of the universe and so on and so forth
or Greenland
is that the anti-monitor was just sort
of whisked away and then suddenly there
was a black lantern central power
battery of course what this ends up
telling us here is the 80 monitor is
basically the source of energy for the
central power battery now of course with
the other lanterns who were here they
all do their best to try to take him out
the problem is that the anti-monitor is
not fully a black lantern and the reason
why that matters is because remember
what a person is full on a black lantern
a massive shock of just white light can
take them out
but because the anti-monitor is not
fully a black lantern yet that's not
enough you need an insane source of
energy a massive amount of energy to be
able to destroy him along with a huge
amount of bright light and so what they
end up doing is they grab the character
of Dove now Dove is an interesting
concept in DC comics honestly I don't
know that much about her I know enough
to be able to say that she's one of
these characters that is that's that
really exists alongside the the concept
of Hawk and Dove originally it was it
was dawn Hall and it was Hank Hall I
think it was I want to say Hank Hall was
Hawk and Donna Hall was was dove but I'm
not 100% sure about that but it's
basically this idea that they represent
law and order they represent you know
war in chaos I think Park represents war
in chaos dove represents law and order
they're basically two opposing
dichotomies that function in unison and
essentially you're superheroes in a lot
of ways in this story right now dawn the
energy that she puts off in terms of
this white light as far as I'm aware is
something that has not been explained
not at the time of this story's given I
don't know if we ever get an explanation
I'm not a hundred percent sure about
that if we do brightest they would
probably be the place where it happens
but the whole idea is that because she
lets off this massive amount of light
energy basically this this white energy
they put her in like a pod and they
shoot her into the brain of the
anti-monitor they literally shoot him
into his head now it's not enough to
destroy him in his entirety remember the
anti-monitor is just this is godly being
he can usually always reconstitute
himself but it does offer a chance for
them to grab the anti-monitor
try to pull him out but it doesn't work
he ends up getting yanked back into the
Black Lantern central power battery and
he continues to be a power source once
more and so again this is really just
John sitting down and saying all right
here are the ways in which to defeat
Necron of the Black Lantern Corps the
anti-monitor
is not one of them and so again this
basically brings y'all Guy Gardner and
all those guys directly back to earth in
an attempt to try to take out you know
nekron and
all the black lanterns and all that kind
of good stuff now again in the last
video we had talked about how we saw the
emergence of the white light entity the
entity of life which is to say
somewhere along the line when the
multiverse came into existence when
everything was created the life entity
came along with it now this is actually
kind of cool because a lot of people
looked at this and they said we'll this
contradicts everything we know about the
origin of the universe actually it
doesn't the origin of the multiverse
stays the same it's still the idea that
there was just this hand that came out
of the beginning of all things and that
hand spawn the creation of the
multiverse and so on and so forth all
this means is that when the multiverse
was new before anything came into
existence when it was basically created
but was just a vacant empty space the
life entity was born and the life entity
what we don't know who made it we don't
know where it came from the life entity
was responsible for the creation of all
life that exists on earth and presumably
out in the universe and so with the
sinestro as the host of the life entity
at the moment following its introduction
of the fact that he seized hold of it
what it does is it gives us the sort of
play-by-play of how everything on earth
unfolded this sense that when the life
entity emerged on earth that it gave
birth to the first single-celled
organisms and then those single-celled
organisms evolved in a multi cell
organisms one of those organisms wanted
to live it wanted to grow it wanted to
continue on and it gave itself the
willpower to do that and in doing so
became the first entity of the emotional
spectrum the ion whale the
representation of willpower in the Green
Lantern mythos in the emotional spectrum
following this there were organisms that
took off from a sea in order to live on
land fearful of their own extinction
that fear gave way to the existence of
parallax we saw things like love which
gave birth to the predator the creation
of the bull based on rage the idea that
something killed something else out of
anger out of malice for the first time
all these different entities are born
from emotion they're born from the idea
that some organism human or otherwise
felt that emotion for the very first
time and when that emotion was felt for
the very first time then it in turn gave
birth to that entity in the emotional
spectrum and so what this means is that
it's basically saying all life in the
universe originated on earth it all
started with earth and that's where the
emotional spectrum came from
and so with this in mind because of the
fact that the white life is basically
the antithesis to the Black Lantern
Corps meaning it's the only thing that
can actually legitimately destroy the
Black Lanterns in their entirety
Metron panics and impale style Sinestro
now again that's an important thing to
keep in mind when it comes to a being
who is in possession of one of the
entities it doesn't mean their physical
body cannot be harmed they can still be
harmed they can still be taken out the
caveat is the white lanterns because the
white Lantern is the representation of
life a person who is a white Lantern can
never truly die so long as they're in
possession of the white lantern entity
we know this with the case of thousand
Estero because while he is basically
split in half none of the other lanterns
who were analyzing him see any singing
to indicate there's been any actual
damage to his body as far as their rings
are concerned looking at the Sinestro
he's just as normal as he ever was and
that's because what the life entity does
is basically heal his physical form and
return him back to normal that's what
we're talking about with this level of
power now Sinestro as the host for the
white lantern is basically god it's
insane how much power he has now the
other thing to keep in mind is that just
because a being becomes a host for the
entity for it for any one of the lantern
entities doesn't mean they suddenly know
everything about everything there's a
learning curve you have to learn what
the life entity is capable of you have
to learn the limits of its power and
that's why in this moment the Sinestro
doesn't just snap his fingers and
everything goes back to normal and
everything's fixed he doesn't know the
full length of what it is he's capable
of all foul Sinestro knows is the
history of the white Lantern's is the
history of the fact that the white
Lantern's represent life the problem is
that the Sinestro is hubris he's full of
arrogance Dowson destro being host for
the white Lantern he's not doing that
because he believes it's the right thing
to do he's doing that because he sees
himself as the best of all of the
lanterns and that's always been the
downfall of Sinestro in every single
circumstance whenever Sinestro gained
some extreme level of power his
arrogance was always his downfall now
his first attempt to take out Necron is
actually pretty successful in the Sin
City rips his heart out and totally
destroys it but keep in mind in the
Green Lantern mythos nekron is the
living embodiment of death and he's
surrounded by black Lantern's and so all
that is up happening is he basically
just transfers his essence to a
another black Lantern and he's reborn
again he's in effect in immutable
indestructible force but only under the
circumstance that his tether is allowed
to remain on earth now the heroes did
not know about this and were not
discovering this until right now
William hand is basically the tether of
Netcom remember William Han was a guy
who was basically just obsessed with
death that death was the only thing that
mattered that everything dies and so
because he was so obsessed with it
Necron effectively latched his essence
and established William Han as a tether
and what this means is that so long as
William hand is dead and as a Black
Lantern necron will always come back and
so the idea is to basically eliminate
William Han but killing him won't do any
good because he's already dead he's
already a Black Lantern and so the only
thing they can do to remove him from
being a tether of necron is to actually
bring him back to life is to essentially
resurrect him now notice this it's a
really cool scenario to unfold here
because it's basically all the heroes
coming to grips with everything I mean
for the most part when you're Barry
Allen and you you know quote-unquote
died during crisis on Infinite Earths
and then you came back you're just kind
of like okay cool that's awesome and
when you're Hal Jordan and you were
paralyzed and you were basically
destroyed and then you came back you're
just like oh that's that's cool whatever
and what's been espoused by necron so
far is that each and every time one of
these characters died he's the one
that's stepped in the way and he's the
one that brought them back but what were
end of what we end up learning here is
this is propaganda
this is nonsense by necron it's him just
running off at the mouth and espousing
things in order to make everyone believe
that he's this you know immutable
indestructible force and he's the
absolute authority on what lives and
what dies in truth that's not the case
the point that how Jordan makes here and
one of the things that he comes to the
realization of is sure when they all
were supposed to have died and that
crown basically stood in the way between
them and the afterlife but it doesn't
mean they had to come back it doesn't
mean they had to return from the dead
what it meant is they chose to come back
they chose to go back to being who they
were before now the intricacies behind
this are wide and varying based on the
character at the time you look at these
characters and you see them going in
greeting death in a wide array of
different ways sometimes willingly and
sometimes unwillingly but the goal that
Hal Jordan mace is when they were
presented with the opportunity to come
back to return to life they chose that
and so Olenick
it was stand in their way and steer them
a different direction they chose what
direction they went in and so our desire
to live is stronger than our desire to
die ie we have a stronger connection to
life than we do to death and the reason
why that matters is because that creates
a click and what ends up happening is
every single member of the Justice
League every single character who has
died and has come back becomes a white
Lantern now it's a fleeting thing it's
only for a momentary thing they actually
channel it all directly into William
hand and effectively resurrect him
basically get his heart pumping again
and bring him back to life in doing so
it destroys the tether that nekron has
on earth and essentially sends him
flying back but not only that remember
we talked about how blackest night was a
soft reboot that DC would use the events
of blackest night to basically begin
going through and deciding who would
live and who would die this is that
moment when a white Lantern ring flies
through Necron it effectively destroys
his heart and sends him back to the
realm of the unliving what this does is
it basically starts seeing the
resurrection of all these different
things the anti-monitor is resurrected
firestorm and Martian Manhunter and Jade
and like Hawk & eobard thawne Maxwell
Lord all these characters DC just starts
bringing back and that's the point of
blackest night the point of blackest
night is for DC to sit down and say we
have an event where everybody's gonna
die we're gonna do a clean slate
everybody's gonna be killed then we're
gonna introduce the white Lantern's then
we're gonna use the power of the white
lanterns to decide who basically gets
resurrected and who goes back to being
dead when the power of the Black Lantern
rings are destroyed it's basically a lot
of the most popular characters it's DC
in a lot of ways consolidating their
entire publication lineup and reducing
the number of heroes that they currently
have out there and that's why you end up
seeing a lot of these characters who had
previously died walking around after the
events of blackest night going into
brightest day is because they were all
effectively resurrected and so once
everything comes to an end you know once
it's all said and done the question
becomes well then what happened to the
white light it's apparently it's gone
now you know nobody's in possession of
it anymore and so what geoff johns does
is he teases the events of brightest day
by basically saying there's a white
Lantern power battery out there now
there's basically going to be a white
Lantern core but how that number
progresses what happens to them is
anybody's guess and we'll have to wait
till blanket or two brightest day to
find out without being said guys we're
going
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to comment explain and make
sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the Rob cork if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and yeah we are finished with
blackest night we are done the blackest
night double uploads are done because I
was getting kind of burned down on black
and snide to be honest with you guys
but uh but yeah we are finished so
anyway guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]